hello reject nation I am G Elba I am J
hump we are going to talk about some
movie news that is sweeping the
Twittersphere at the moment it's about
Jimmy gun you just got fired from
guardians of the galaxy three over some
weird-ass sweetie sweetie I believe this
gosh guys I don't know if you know about
this Oh Jay Simpson may have killed we
don't know for sure well we do know is
that he got that merchandise back and
now he's in prison oh geez James Gunn
news before we get into that I want to
say thank you to everyone who's been
joining us on our patreon page yeah over
there we do TV show reactions for many
of shows that includes attack on Titan
my hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Gotham Riverdale and
supernatural also weekly Q&A so go check
us out if you'd like to shameful plugs
on to the movie news here this is coming
from the rap and to quote them holy
poached Batman that delivered great
Robin door yeah Jamie Gunn is in talks
to write for Suicide Squad too with
possibly directing Suicide Squad -
supposedly this is gonna be something
that's very much different which is a
good thing I think you know Suicide
Squad has its limited fan base let's
lead with this as if this is potentially
true otherwise this is a waste of time
then for all we know this could be a
waste of time if James Gunn is to write
and/or direct Suicide Squad - first of
all good ballsy move there - Warren just
according to what everyone on Twitter
saying yeah yeah I mean it's a gutsy
move for sure and it definitely drives a
wedge in that Marvel vs. DC vibe you
know oh definitely I mean it's it's a
gutsy move but it's also not a
surprising move I guess I thought like
they would eventually recruit him for
something that was not an established
property however Suicide Squad I think
that if they were to use the kind of
style James Gunn can provide would be a
wonderful transition if we're talking
about
just what James Gunn is known to provide
I think that's a smart transition
because the first Suicide Squad is a
pretty kinetic film it's got some like
weird comedy in there and some misplaced
darkness it doesn't really feel dark
it's a strange kind of mashup of a movie
but we're not here to review the first
Suicide Squad James Gunn is known to
kind of deal with those elements but in
a smoother style in a smoother fashion
something that really works and clicks
and connects that's why I think he would
be a good transitional choice for
Suicide Squad too as much as I can to
see him take on a different property and
essentially turn that into guardians of
the game working with kind of an
established cast maybe introducing some
new squad members highlighting some
other ones I think this could be a
really good fit I would especially be
excited and I doubt this what happened
and I'm speaking strongly for some
reason if this was r-rated because James
Gunn comes from an r-rated background
you know hence I grew up watching of
James Gunn where films like super and
slither you know like very hard oh Romeo
and Juliet yeah see everyone kind of
wanted an r-rated Suicide Squad to begin
with I feel like that damn is gonna
break at some point before too much
longer because especially on the heels
of the venom argument and stuff like
that I feel like all right in
superheroes especially these kinds were
they're very villain centric could
definitely see the light of day more
often now and James Gunn would be the
guy for something like that yeah and I
feel like DC and it might have someone
there who's smart enough to learn that
just because a prior installment made a
crap ton of money doesn't mean you
should stick to that it's the transition
from BBS to justice Lee cuz BBS made a
lot of money and then Justice League
didn't even come close to making that
much money maybe the first Suicide Squad
made three quarters of a billion dollars
you know which is great but you got to
pay attention to the response the movie
had and I really do think that James
Gunn great choice for that for what he
can do
ballsy move you know you gotta raise the
competition say we love competition man
well that'll make some money regardless
of the movie because people will be so
fascinated by the fact that it's James
yeah everyone losing their
is over James Gunn like I got everybody
I got imagine just even despite whatever
the film turns out to be people will
show up just based on that alone you
know oh yeah I would it definitely fits
his sensibility kind of a hundred
percent oh the only thing I would be
concerned about is I feel like they did
successfully cast the first movie I feel
like the first movie has a lot of great
actors I would love to see you get a
second shake at a better version of the
source material so I guess I would be
kind of bummed to see them recast and I
know a lot of people have been like it's
about enough rumors about like who's
like Batista gonna come in and play like
Solomon Grundy or something like that
you know so are we gonna get like all
the Guardians cast playing all the
Suicide Squad people now like would go
that is I think the last thing he's
gonna want to do is remind everybody is
remind everybody and also just you know
give a middle finger to Marvel in such a
public sphere I feel like it's a ballsy
move on the Warner Brothers side but I
don't feel like it's a disrespectful
move on James Gunn side if that makes
sense I don't I don't view this as James
Gunn's like going Oh toe to toe with
Marvel I'm like he needs work man yeah
he's going to another place that is
suited to him and DC's kind of in a you
know to figure it out like they're still
in there figuring out stage and their
plans are constantly shifting here and
there who the hell knows if this is this
is a rumor we we don't know for sure
even if they are really talking that
could just be them talking it's like
yeah they have a lot of talks with a lot
of people so they're not in a
negotiation side here I'm sure it's just
a talk at most of you interested you
know and what would your take be what
would you want to do with this you know
and I feel like James Gunn's a kind of
guy who would only take on a job behind
the camera if he's passionate about it
is he gonna be passionate about Suicide
Squad you in a giant course-correction
of a film you know a lot of pressure for
sure there's a lot of pressure but I'm
sure whatever he can deliver will
arguably be better give more his
territory than it was David a yeah yeah
a hundred percent I feel like you know
given the track record WB is established
with wanting to do creator or you know
director helmed superhero movies and
then kind of constantly going back on
that decision and tampering with that
decision I feel like James Gunn is a
choice where yeah you would have a guy
confident enough in this arena that I
don't think they would need to do that
yeah having James Wan the guy where
you're like this dude's a solid enough
filmmaker to where I gotta imagine he's
not gonna be too challenging to what we
need from him but at the same time he's
gonna bring a lot of personality and I
feel like James Gunn can do that in a
way that David Ayer might not have been
able to because Suicide Squad was such
an out of the box thing for his
particular career fingers crossed but I
feel like we could just get a unified
movie from a guy like James Gunn who
does have like enough clout to be like
Marvel rested a whole bunch of faith in
me before bunch of random stuff came
back to light so maybe you should listen
to what I have to say if Ari cuts and
stuff become an issue
alright guys but before we end this
video I wanted to give a patron of the
day shoutout to a man named Joe breeze
Eck Jobriath is a sexy man all the way
from Chicago two weeks ago he just had I
believe his seventeenth birthday
I don't know i might be 14 years off on
there because he's actually he just hit
the big 31 i want you to know that if
you're having a midlife crisis it's
totally okay and you should be having a
midlife crisis my friend life is scary
and if you're 31 and you are not where
you really imagine you would be you need
to get your [ __ ] together dude it's a
tough world out there man it's a tough
world life does not tend to those who
want it tends to those who deserve so
you better get your ass
off the couch and increase your pledge
on patreon because that's the way you
really get what you want by helping the
real rejects out even more that's the
only way
just keep funneling it in through here
and especially Joe you by giving exactly
yeah so Joe if you want to overcome that
insecurity of your age this is the way
this is the way now I do I hope you had
a great birthday we'd we've talked
before and he works in the medical field
he's already helping people out so I'm
sure you're living a very fulfilling
life love you buddy I know you went to
Disneyland or something I forget on your
birthday I'm going off memory here i
hope that this next year is even better
than last year alright guys well what do
you think about James Gunn potentially
writing and/or directing Suicide Squad -
do you think that we should cast louis
c.k as one of the Suicide Squad members
since he can still work or maybe Mel
Gibson he has one of the people in the
movie get them all get them all I know
that's the dream is a gun script Mel
Gibson directing there you go
there you go oh we're getting a whole
bunch of people together who aren't
desirable in a Hollywood movie all right
guys well you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell again notify one of our you another
drill and check us out on patreon